hallo guck mal ich habe mich beschieden
hinter sich ein bisschen ein blog macht
weiter und es wird gleich ziemlich
unnötig das hinspiel gerade fifa fifa 10
über zehn wissenspool viel links und
kommunen spielern an
mit kurz leute zeigen den spielstand um
zu beweisen wie krass sebastian ist und
das ist bayer leverkusen
ich habe den in flagranti mit dem link
der erwischt
nein dafür kriegt einen dritten er hat
drei tore gemacht
leute ich weiß gar nicht warum ich das
schon wieder machen typen aber ich hab
da lust lust nicht irgendwelchen ist in
rhina ständig von aufwand als ich in den
raum kommt
wer eine ahnung ich bin gerade nach
hause kommt beim kühler und city oder
hotspot ist und direkt ihre stellen wir
können meine spiele highlights zeigen
fokussiert auf meine fresse attacke
bereit was wie kulturlos das würde ich
auch controller gesetzt du hast nein ich
habe nicht darauf kabel auf dem cover
die schwere voll ich habe nie die taxis
noch drin
dass ich trotzdem drauf gesetzt des
weges mit deaktiviert wurden nein als
ich recht da die recht hast du nicht du
penner dass hier was ist trotzdem
verlauf ich habe auf keinen fall auf 4
nein das schön einfach so viele täter
damals ihr business mal warum war
einfach 24
das ist hier der immense style fokus
jedoch die wollen scheiße alter heute
lasse ich nicht erzählen von wegen wir
wollten im team sehen was soll das
johanna typ gespielt findet jetzt
geschrieben schatz in die kommentare
warum hat toni kroos 0 6 punkte man was
sein lässt heute schreibt auch dachten
die kommentare juni findet die ich soll
mir in linx besorgen und weitwinkel
objektiv zu ungewohnte optik oder sagt
simons wo wohnst du mittlerweile kommt
das physische umbenannt nein das ist in
diesem fall nicht weil ich bin's er sagt
man doch so genannten hat er sich simons
genannt auf twitter vor der abfahrt
januar wenn du siehst dass apple cent
ist auf jeden fall gegen das denken
hey auf der kunde scooter services team
investieren gerade warum wir den scheiß
anschaut habe ich mich dieses ausnehmen
irgendwie lustig
wir wollen auf jeden fall die tage ich
weiß wie viel comics heute sogar
aufnehmen
so kann jetzt mehr ich werde euch mal
unten ein
straw poll link oder jeder von frauke
linken die beschreibung finden könnt ihr
abstimmen ob wir das okay findet oder
nicht oder sagt es ok es ein bisschen
kritisch für junge zuschauer dass wir so
ein kleines trinkspiel game machen
ich habe ihm so eine coole elgato shrek
kart zugeschickt bekommen noch passion
for i halt und da können wir einfach vom
iphone irgendwie aufnimmt jason terry
wie wir ein paar spielen spielen spielen
diese drei stücke oder so und da muss
immer der verlierer drei zahlen drei
euro pro person
die zahl 33 uhr fraglich und wir wollen
so spielen also mit wasser und irgend
einem klaren schnaps man dann halt immer
zufällig aus wir mussten das könnte
relativ lustig werden
wir werden natürlich auch nicht hat aber
kein also lassen wir wissen dass ich
packe ich den stepper link unten die
beschreibung und dann nehmen wir das
einfach die tage mal auf oder so ich
wollte sowieso mit ein paar vom bzö mal
zocken und dann kann man das verschenken
verbinden was man hier zweck bin extra
kuschelt du dich mit dem ding was er
nicht weggekratzt und dann nicht mehr
die mathematik open dann hoffe ich
wir fahren nicht genauso sehr wie ich
maske abgeht was ist das aber ich habe
ganz auf gelesen dass solche videos
beliebt sind bei euch bitte ich würde
mir und ich werde mir anschauen muss man
schauen dass das so bleibt